this is a rare sight I've never caught
them in the water
I've never gotten it in the water before
known as the Indiana Jones of wildlife
protection zoologist Allen Rabinowitz
was a tireless force in protecting
endangered animals and their ecosystems
particularly big cats Rabinowitz who
died this week at the age of 64 saved
the lives of countless tigers jaguars
and other at-risk species by getting
their protection on to the agendas of
leaders in Asia Africa and Latin America
dr. Howard Quigley is a Jaguar expert
and a lifelong friend of Rabinowitz like
Indiana Jones he went places that other
people didn't go he tried to make
discoveries that other people weren't
going to make because he had the energy
and he had the wherewithal to not sit at
this desk and just be writing about
biology but the do biology in 2011 Bob
Simon profiled will be knowit's for 60
minutes one night having that his team
snared this young lady and put her to
sleep for a while this is the same cat
you saw swimming this afternoon it's
likely it looks as if it probably is
born in Brooklyn Rabinowitz had a
stutter so severe he was unable to
communicate with peers and teachers but
he found he could relate to animals he
would spend endless hours at the Bronx
Zoo lion house where he considered the
cats to be his kindred spirits in their
isolation and silence it was there that
he vowed to become the voice of the
voiceless in the following years
Rabinowitz overcame his stutter and
fulfilled that pledge
among his life's achievements he created
the who kong valley sanctuary the
world's largest tiger reserve in myanmar
the jaguar year which for the last 15 or
20 minutes set up the Jaguar corridor a
series of protected areas that run from
Mexico to Argentina and founded the
Panthera group an organization dedicated
to saving wild cats around the globe
in addition rabinowitz is credited with
discovering four new species of mammals
including the tiny leaf deer the most
primitive deer species in the world
seriously I was the accident the
personable and often funny Rabinowitz
also wrote books made documentaries and
mentored thousands of young scientists
put his legacy in a nutshell I guess it
would be that he made a difference he
didn't turn away from a challenge
and that he kept his focus on the
conservation of the animals that he
loved so much you think about him as a
child not being able to communicate and
finding these cats as his kindred
spirits that he called and then the work
he did to help them in the future is
really amazing when you think about it
and when you think about those young
people that he touched and really
incentivized
there's a Brooklyn boy from the Brooklyn
right my kids go to that zoo